je préfère parler de séparatisme que
communautarisme c'est ce qu'a répété
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui à mulhouse
où il entame une série de visites pour
prendre ce sujet à bras le corps c'est
en tout cas ce qu'il a déclaré
alors on va vous tenir au courant de ce
qui va déclarer il va prendre
l'apparence la parole c'est une c'est
une allocution mais ce n'est pas encore
le grand discours qu'il doit prononcer
sur la question et c'est une des
questions qu'on vous pose aujourd'hui
qu'attendez-vous des manuels macron sur
cette question attendez vous des
solutions alors en attendant votre
réponse je vous propose d'écouter celles
ce matin de christian jacob s'était sur
europe 1 on n'attend pas que le
président de la république fasse des
phrases on attend qu'ils agissent
or aujourd'hui d'actions il n'en a pas
eu depuis deux ans et demi rien n'a été
fait il a reporté ce discours combien de
fois la première fois qu'il en a parlé
c'est en janvier 2018 puis en juin 2018
puis en janvier 2019
et tout ça pour arriver à dire est-ce
que c'est du communautarisme ou est-ce
que c'est du séparatisme
mais de qui se moque t'on alors alexis
on parle beaucoup de sémantique
ces dernières heures le terme
séparatisme qui a été utilisée par enel
macron la veille était déjà dans le
figaro il ya un an par des intellectuels
signataires d'un manifeste qui voulait
mettre en garde contre contre contre ce
phénomène peut s'arrêter cet appel avait
été jugée notre part le gouvernement
l'exécutif zx c'était pas bien parce que
c'était stigmatisant c'était je suis
passé le mot islamophobe avait été
prononcé mais c'était quand même
vaguement idée donc bon alors maintenant
par ces artistes mais franchement ces
querelles sémantiques ne paraît un peu
vaine on va dire oui le séparatiste pas
le communautarisme parce que le
communautarisme on fait l'amalgamé entre
les communautés tandis que le
séparatisme
on va dire on met en avant le caractère
réel d'un certain nombre de mener
islamistes dans certains pans qui
passent dans des pans entiers du pays
donc c'est le mot est mieux choisi mais
en même temps ça montre pas la démarche
qui était aussi démarche réelle qui ne
m'a pas uniquement de se séparer de la
ville et de la vie démocratique et
républicaine c'est une démarche de
conquête d'affirmer des idéaux sait pas
que c'est pas bon bon enfin là pour le
coup je pense que ces questions de mots
comme la question de savoir s'il faut
traiter parce qu'on nous a présentés on
a quand même entendu ça c'était une
grande avancée de dire que
jusqu'à présent et même macron disais
qu'il fallait traiter séparément les
questions de laïcité de communautarisme
et de radicalisation et que dorénavant
on allait les traiter ensemble
moi je veux bien tout ce qu'on fait mais
à un moment faut dire qu on fait quoi
séparément ensemble mais pour quoi faire
séparatisme on peut appeler ça comme ne
tarissent mon peuple et sa islamistes
bon peuple et sa touche qu'on veut mais
là encore on fait quoi et nous dire que
si la solution c'est de dire on va
remettre le cfcm au centre du jeu parce
que c est une institution formidable
dont le vice président explique la jeune
milla n'a que ce qu'elle mérite je vois
pas très bien en quoi ça va arranger les
choses
non le donc moi je suis je tant mieux si
mais là c'est vrai qu'à un moment il
faut prendre des décisions faut faire
des choses
nicole nous dit de toute façon avec
macron qu'on parle de séparatisme ou de
communautarisme c'est idem c'est
toujours des mots ce qu'il peut y avoir
des solutions de nier à votre avis je
partage l'avis qui a été exprimée sur
les mots c'est comme enlever le nom de
l'ena j'ai l'impression qu'on se trompe
un peu de cibles
et puis mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde pour
reprendre la formule célèbre de camus
donc on a me semble-t-il deux sujets
sains
d'abord on a un appareil légal et un
ensemble un édifice légal construit
depuis la fin du 19ème siècle qui
détermine les principes républicains il
faut qu'on l'appliqué
la preuve la question numéro un c'est
d'appliquer avec rigueur les règles
républicaines prenez les prenez la
liberté d'opinion
le principe républicain c'est que la
liberté d'opinion y compris la liberté
d'opinion religieuse existe donc on a le
droit de confesser la religion qu'on
veut y compris dans l'espace public mais
on a aussi le droit de critiquer la
religion et donc il faut qu'on rappelle
et quand le garde des sceaux fait une
telle erreur d'appréciation sur la loi
républicaine donc la première des choses
c'est d'appliquer par exemple dans le
service public on ne peut pas ne pas
serrer la main
un conducteur de la ratp n'a pas le
droit de 2,2 de ne pas serrer la main
d'une de ses collègues au motif que
c'est une femme
il ya un principe d'égalité des hommes
et des femmes qui doit être appliquée
donc la première des choses la première
c'est que vous appelez ça il ya le
rappelait ce matin ici même le sait
c'est aussi la responsabilité des élus
dans le respect notamment de cet édifice
que vous évoquez la loi de 1905 quand on
n'a pas cessé depuis 20 ans de
distribuer des baux emphytéotiques 99
ans c'est ce que monsieur delanoë a
donné comme bail emphytéotique pour
l'institut des cultures de l'islam dans
le xviiie à paris qui a été condamné
pour illégalité par de nombreuses
juridictions y compris le conseil d'état
est pourtant qu'il est toujours là avec
des subventions publiques à la à n'en
plus finir
est-ce que je pense que la loi
républicaine c'est aussi la possibilité
pour les cultes de s'exercer et la
question d'offrir à nos compatriotes
musulmans des lieux de culte doit être
réglée mais mais si vous me permettez je
vends ce bout de la route mais
heureusement donc un la loi républicaine
la loi républicaine c'est le droit la
possibilité pour les cultes de s'exercer
pour les gens de librement confesser
leur religion mais c'est le droit aussi
de les critiquer il faut qu'on soit très
ferme à sucre et la deuxième chose à
faire de son but il c'est une bataille
c'était la solution c'est ça consiste
d'abord à ça à faire appli
et partout la loi républicaine magasins
et la deuxième chose à faire me
semble-t-il c'est une bataille
intellectuelle
c'est une bataille idéologique pour
reconquérir l'idée d'un terme qui
aujourd'hui paraît désuet et presque
contestable de l'assimilation je pense
que il faut qu'on en revienne aux vieux
principes énoncés par clermont tonnerre
pour les juifs au moment de leur
émancipation à la révolution française
tout aux juifs en tant qu'individu et
rien en tant que nation si les forces
politiques démocratiques de ce pays un
applique rigoureusement la règle
républicaine et 2 rappelle chaque fois
que nécessaire qu'en france on n'est pas
dans un pays de communautarisme on a un
idéal républicain qui font notre notre
égalité on aura fait un grand pas
aujourd'hui à sa tante de commander hd
au compromis prétendument raisonnable
avec ce communautarisme contre lequel il
faut lutter barbazo parce que je dis
l'islam politique à une stratégie
les frères musulmans les salafistes août
7 cet ensemble de la frérot sphère qui
agit en france depuis la fin des années
90 si elle a réussi à avoir une
influence grandissante qui est la sienne
aujourd'hui à développer cette industrie
du halal à généraliser le port du voile
de tous les stigmates de l'islam
politique c'est-à-dire à transformer une
fois en une idéologie c'est parce
qu'elle a été systématiquement soutenu
par un certain nombre d'élus naïvement
pour certains - naïvement pour d'autres
plus tôt par clientélisme électoral qui
se cherchaient des interlocuteurs est
effectivement en général les stratèges
des frères musulmans qui ne sont pas des
gens qui viennent de la campagne qui
sont plutôt des gens éduqués souvent des
diplômés ont su utiliser les voies
légales pour devenir les partenaires de
l'aider et lui et de l'état donc deux
solutions semblent mais là c'est
vraiment à l'état aux élus d'être aussi
ferme que possible et moi je suis désolé
car ils ont un peu les baux
emphytéotiques c'est terminé six cent
cinquante mille euros de subventions
publiques à l'institut des cultures de
l'islam à paris dans le xviiie excusez
moi c'est de la subvention publique la
mairie de paris c'est anormal 230000
euros à la fameuse mosquée an nour qui
n'est même pas encore fini de construire
à mulhouse c'est la mairie de mulhouse
qui la donne est donc cet argent là n'a
pas aller et la problématique
aujourd'hui qui se posent par rapport à
l'islam de france monsieur macron
veut alors monsieur castaner veut
remettre le cfcm au centre alors que
monsieur macro lui veut mettre la mif au
sens l'association des musulmans pour
l'islam de france dirigée par hakim el
karoui pour sa branche culturelle et par
tarik obrou pour sa branche cultuelle on
a là un repère je ne parle pas de
monsieur hakim el karoui mais de
l'ensemble des théologiens et des imams
rassembler certains ensembles deux
frères musulmans défroqué est-ce que
c'est cet islam là de france que
monsieur macron c'est pas parce qu'on a
fait passer une famille bah écoutez
quand on a en tout cas vous avez coller
un tract pour le front national en 1975
ça vous poursuit encore jusqu'en 2020
par contre quand vous étiez frères
musulmans j'ai encore quatre ans alors
là tout d'un coup en 2020 ça ne compte
plus non moi je suis désolé votre passé
parle pour vous monsieur tarek oubrou
jusqu'en encore très peu monsieur bajra
fils et bien d'autres qui sont sans
parler de abdelhak nabawi chez qui
monsieur castaner vient rompre le jeûne
du ramadan tous ces gens là sont des
frères musulmans déclaré quand on
connaît un peu l'histoire des frères
musulmans venir nous dire que c'était il
ya deux ans mais maintenant c'est fini
qui peut croire à ces sornettes juste
une question denis dans ce que souligne
et barbare le fait par exemple sur le
cas de la mosquée mme nouria un papier
non fier aujourd'hui qui la raconte sert
qu à partir du moment où il n'ya plus
les subventions on se rend compte que
on peut les fidèles l'argent des fidèles
ne suffit pas à construire des mosquées
ans qu'on ne veut dire on ne peut pas
sinon on va alimenter la radicalité
d'abord un quand les enquêtes d'opinion
sur l'islam de france sur les français
de confession isli musulmane montre que
la partie vraiment radical est pour
l'instant minorité a même très
minoritaire - chez les jeunes mais en
gros c'est 25 à 30% de nos contraintes
rilsan quand même des jeunes musulmans
français qui sont non mais si si si si
si vous ne respectez pas moi je suis
évidemment très favorable à
l'application stricte de la loi
républicaine mais si inversement vous ne
respectez pas le droit à la liberté
d'opinion religieuse pour ses seules
pour nous sommes compatriotes musulmans
si vous voulez discriminés et vous voyez
bien que les juifs ont des synagogues
les les juifs sont présents sur le sol
de france depuis le premier siècle de
notre ère les catholiques ont évidemment
des églises
s'agissant d'une communauté qui n'a pas
pu construire ccme ces mosquées parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas là maintenant et
bien très bien donc
donc c'est vrai lieu de l'état on ferait
mieux les problèmes ce sont les mosquées
cathédrales la mosquée à nous il lui
manque trois millions
mais évidemment qu'avec une mosquée de
10 mille mètres carrés ça va pas arrêter
les musulmans de 2,2 mulhouse qui vont
pouvoir se la payer par contre peut-être
une mosquée à taille normale
plusieurs mosquées à taille humaine
justement on n'a pas cet effet de foule
et de masse
ça peut-être plus d'enfants vous avez
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
vous axez plus pressants à financer un
mois j'ai été profondément touché par
l'incendié de notre dame
pourquoi est-ce que diable les
catholiques auraient le droit d'avoir
une cathédrale les juifs auraient le
droit sur ce n'est pas au contribuable
français de payer pour les mosquées ni
pour les synagogues ni pour les églises
aujourd'hui des juifs la communauté
juive où les chrétiens la part de qui
s'organise
c'est bien parce que vous savez très
bien que les élèves vous savez très bien
que les catholiques et les juifs ont
bénéficié de leur histoire et du fait
qu'ils ont hérité de l'histoire passée
des synagogues qui avait été construite
sous le régime précédent d'autres se
sont reconstruites après la loi de 1905
de nombreuses synagogues ont été
construites après l'allemagne se trouve
que si on veut que si on veut être si on
veut être rigoureux dans le combat
contre le radicalisme islamique contre
les communautarismes il faut qu'on soit
généreux dans la possibilité offerte à
nos compatriotes musulmane musulmans de
confesser leur religion librement
oui vous parler de leur territoire moi
je vois lille on le prendrait confessé
librement et le fait est que 7,7 ce que
cette expression de la région soient
subventionnés sur fonds publics c'est ce
sont deux choses différentes à l'élite
moi je le dis je ne pense pas que ce
soit nécessaire des notables mais à la
limite on pourrait l'envisager si on
était sûr de ce que l'on finance si
lente et sûre de ce que dit de ce qui se
dit là où on le finance
or c'est le contraire dire que chaque
fois qu'on met des fonds publics on se
rend compte que et on a tout essayé le
cfcm le conseil ceux ci le conseil sur à
l'arrivée ce sont toujours les plus
radicaux qui l'emportent et à l'arrivée
on s'en rend compte il ya personne n'a
aucun contrôle sur ce qui est dit dans
ces mosquées c'est ça aujourd'hui les
vrais sujets comment est-ce qu'on
contrôle ce qui se faisait comment est
ce qu'on arrive à expulser un imam il
faut il faut quinze ans pour l'expulser
1er juillet bernard oger dans son
enquête a bien montré que parfois vous
avez une mosquée où l'administration de
la mosquée se passe très bien mais il
accepte de faire venir des prédicateurs
itinérant et c'est par eux que parce
tout c est sans parler que le prêcheur
youtube qui sont extrêmement à avignon
le fait pas on ne sait pas mais un site
internet d'un risque de tout faire mais
les prêcheurs youtube donne de l'argent
donne aux subventions de façon directe
ou indirecte détournés ou pour à
l'arrivée n'avoir aucun contrôle sur
hyères et aucune sanction jamais jamais
jamais car la moindre sanction est
systématiquement d'une part islamophobe
d'autre part sanctionner par les
tribunaux du strate yves qui disent que
s'ils empruntent à ceux ci à cela et le
conseil d'état à 90 fois sur cent à nu
les jurés composent
faire gagner vous avez encore parlé et
j'ai une question alors là vraiment
spécifiquement pour vous bruno
retailleau dit seul le retour de l'état
déterminé pourra vaincre la fermeture de
ces enclaves sur elle même nom parle
même plus de mosquées on parle de ces
notamment de ces quartiers de reconquête
républicaine d'excusés mais là il faut
quand même il faut quand même l'état
je ne sais pas convaincu que d'un combat
idéologique comme il ya deux voies
doivent s'appuyer volet de la politique
la joconde et non mais moi je parle de
combat idéologique d'ailleurs je ne suis
pas convaincu sur un combat politique en
premier lieu et j'aime bien faire le
parallèle avec le nôtre totalitarisme
qui a longtemps plané sur nos têtes
c'est le totalitarisme communiste au 20e
siècle et bien qu'en ce totalitarisme
plats nationaux tête et pas qu'un peu
puisque les grandes figures qui
utilisent l apologie de l'urss et de
polpot avaient leur leur rond de
serviette dans les grands médias et dans
les grandes universités est bien l'enjeu
pour les intellectuels et partisan de
l'assignation occidental en jeu pour les
rémois rond les gens font ça relève
toutes ces figures là c'est de défaire
de déconstruire ces idéologies sur le
terrain est bien aux dons pour vous ce
samedi l'heure était donc c'est un
combat mon avis qui doit appartenir au
monde académique médiatique au monde de
la culture au monde est un compact
d'être décomplexée c'est à dire que s'il
s'avère effectivement qu'une religion
l'islam radical ou l'islam tout court
s'il s'avère que cette religion est un
principe est intrinsèquement vicié
incompatible avec notre civilisation
il faut être décomplexé avec l'idée de
déconstruit cette religion en tant que
telle elle était au bout de chaque
commune question charlie hebdo par
exemple a essayé de le faire à sa façon
ils ont vu que vous avez vu le
le pti le tribut qu'ils ont payé bien
vous faut quand même donner pas il faut
quand même de là pour quoi faire
c'est pas un fonctionnaire voulu crois
pas qu'on peut changer les coeurs et et
convertir les esprits il ya coup
d'arrêtés ministériels de décret de loi
donc non je pense c'est pas facile
effectivement c'est un combat qui n'est
qu'ils n'auraient d'ailleurs pas que de
la raison c'est aussi beaucoup de
séduction comment séduire toutes ces
populations aux vertus de la
civilisation occidentale
comment les amener à prendre une
distance critique à l'égard de leur
culte s'il s'avère que ce tube est en
soi en fait incompatible avec notre
civilisation comment les amener à
épouser la peau stasis il faut aller
jusque là c'est là un combat culturel
qui ne relèvent pas mon avis de la
fonction publique d'un fonctionnaire ou
des policiers dans les quartiers parce
que pour rétablir de l'homme pour
rétablir l'ordre tout bêtement la
sécurité armés aux logis vient de will
et le sujet pour les gens qui vivent
dans l'ensemble de quartier il n'est pas
c'est pas des grandes querelles de
philosophiques idéologiques c'est
celui-là jour le jour la pression d'une
part donne de l'islam fondamentaliste
qui restreint leur espace de liberté
d'expression et et qui devient de plus
une chape de plus en plus pesante et
d'autre part des trafic de la drogue dea
de la délinquance est rare et tout ça a
gueulé d'ailleurs même mâcon maintenant
dit tout ça il me les faut qu'on traite
ensemble et bien pour ça vous aurez
toujours besoin d'un arsenal pénal et
d'un arsenal sécuritaire il me semble
aussi que si on si si on acceptait de
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont ce
qu on est retenu à l'idée de dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont par la peur
de stigmatiser l'ensemble des de nos
compatriotes musulmans et donc on n'ose
pas dire qu'une bonne part des
agressions homophobes qu'une bonne part
des agressions des jeunes filles dans
les banlieues que la totalité ou la
quasi-totalité des actes antisémites
sont le fait de cet islam radical
on est tétanisée à l'idée de
l'accusation l'islamophobie donc la
première des choses à faire c'est qu'on
sait que je partage votre avis la
première des choses à faire et le
gouvernement doit donner un exemple
c'est de dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont c'est-à-dire de dire il ne s'agit
pas de stigmatiser l'ensemble des
musulmans de france car la majorité
d'entre eux confesse le cas
moment sa religion mais il s'agit de
dire clairement qu'une partie de nos
ennemis aujourd'hui de d'incivilité
graves et parfois de crimes sont commis
par ces islamistes radicaux et on doit
les combattre
depuis les années 2000 j'ai contribué à
un livre les territoires perdus de la
république
on était en 2002 pierre andré taguieff
la même année et depuis a publié de
nombreux ouvrages ont prêché dans le
désert
y compris dans les granges les grands
les grandes tablées médiatique de
l'époque
nous on voulait pas nous écouter parce
qu'on stigmatisait donc voilà on
recommandera donc les territoires perdus
de la république et on recommandera
également le hors série que le figaro
figaro enquête avait fait d'ailleurs sur
le séparatisme islamique islamistes
c'était il y a un an et quitte à
retrouver sur le sur le figaro store la
première chose à faire nous dit claudius
et de fermer les mosquées radical en
dehors des discours on attend des actes
nous dit emile les églises ont été
financés en leur temps par la population
du nicole qu'on fasse de même pour les
muscles et qu'elle ce film qu'il se
financent eux-mêmes et arcus guy nous
dit je n'attends rien macron s'est
soumis s'il parle il n'agira jamais
c'était la question d'ailleurs que on
vous posez sur twitter selon vous
emmanuel macron peut-il apporter des
solutions pour contrer le séparatisme
islamiste est en tout cas pour ceux qui
ont répondu vous êtes sceptiques 70% de
nom et 29 % de oui
30 % de oui quelles sont les solutions
que les partenaires sociaux vont trouver
pour financer les 12 milliards de
déficit pour les retraites c'est l'objet
de la conférence de financement qui
s'est ouverte ce matin à cette
conférence de financement a été
consentie par le par le gouvernement et
selon l'ancien ministre